stay tuned to the end of the video to
find out what's in the bag
good morning john it is friday my final
day of pizza miss the final day of
pizzamas as usual it has gone by far too
fast and i have ended pizza mix with
more video ideas that i started it with
so
i don't i guess i could just do this
which makes sense because in 2007 i did
we did this this is what this was every
week so i guess i understand how we did
it back then but i don't really
understand how we're still doing this
now there's something confusing but also
really lovely about doing a thing that
isn't a thing i think a lot in the
visual metaphor of paths a path is nice
because like people have been on it and
so you can see ahead you know where
you're going and you know where you're
going to end up i think it's safe to say
that this community is off of most of
the well-trod pads so sometimes it feels
like we can't see very far ahead and i
can guarantee you
we don't know where we're going i hope
people don't think we have a destination
in mind we don't but it's exciting off
the path high chances of tripping and
falling absolutely occasionally
uncomfortable sure
chances of ending up somewhere you
didn't expect very high the exceptional
storyteller and video maker johnny
harris left a comment on my last pizza
miss video i've been a die-hard fan of
this channel for one decade now but i
still don't understand what pizza miss
is and i kind of love that me too and i
love it so much like every year i kind
of know what pizza miss is a little less
which is perfect it's confusing but it's
low stakes and it's lovely what is
pizzamis what is vlogbrothers what is
nerdfighteria like i feel a little like
i'm bragging right now but like
is not fitting into any of the boxes
that have been defined well i'm sorry
it's just this isn't what your normal
youtube community looks and acts like
which is great it makes it hard to talk
about sometimes which can be bad but
also it makes it so that we continue to
be under the radar which i like let's
stay down here anyway it used to be that
pizzamas was like extra work for me now
it's less work because i don't do the
rest of my work and it just becomes a
time when i get to be creative all the
time it's like a creative vacation where
instead of working on work i work on a
different kind of work that isn't
working i mean it can be hard work like
i worked very hard on that facebook
video there was a lot of sitting and
staring and researching and writing and
editing and editing and editing and
forgetting about lunch and etc but even
after all these years making a
vlogbrothers video never feels like
going to work like the goal isn't
productivity it's just making things and
seeing if people like them which maybe
is part of why we started donating all
the profit from pizza mess like it helps
it not feel like work if we're not
making money speaking of which at the
beginning of pizza miss we thought we
were going to do some discount codes
throughout pizza mess that we said that
we were to the people who aren't going
to get text messages but then we felt
bad about it because we were like felt
like punishing the people who bought
early that was mean so we decided not to
do that but we also said we were going
to so as a middle road let me present to
you the coupon code nickelback which
will give you five cents off of any
order at pizzamist.com and if you don't
like that idea it was john's idea
if you do like it it was also john's
idea i'm just the one who clicked the
buttons to make it happen and if you're
doing gift shopping right now i think
the only other vlogbrothers thing we're
doing before the end of the year is the
relaunch of the awesome socks club just
so you know what's going on in our
commerce schedule and finally i would
like to introduce you to
my cat its name has not been decided yet
it turns out it's difficult to choose a
name when a four-year-old is involved so
at the moment everyone this is kitty he
has tried on a lot of different names
they all fit him differently but we have
not settled on a name yet but regardless
already i love him so much he's so cute
and no you don't get to vote on the name
that's up to oren thank you all so much
for a wonderful pizza miss the pizzamas
store will remain open through the
weekend but this is the last time that i
will be telling you on a video that
pizzamist.com is a place where you can
get pizza in this stuff five cents off
with the coupon nickelback all profit
goes to charity and none of these items
will ever be available ever again after
this sunday and john i will see you on
tuesday